bro what is the future for most these
endly fans women are they going to be
living lives of Despair and
loneliness well I mean you can kind of
look at the ghosts of like none of this
is you right so like what what's
happened to Nia
Khalifa she she got married like five
times yeah yeah but but the thing is the
damage is it because the argument is
always there's always going to be a set
and and yes there's going to be a s but
look at history what's happened like I
can even find you the equivalent like I
just studied a chick on the way here S A
51e Cas oh he's
where like from a hundred years ago like
none of these people are like a hundred
years ago there were still harlots
foures um I mean most of them were like
part of the suffragist movement for like
um the feminists of the time they they
parade even out in Coco Chanel she's a
war she done alone yeah and that's like
why you think so just CU J stop being a
[__] yeah I mean well think about it
when you're a [__] if you're if you're
if you're an ala Faller right the longer
you do it the harder it's going to be in
Quin it's the same thing with purpose SK
so you know they always say so you know
if a chick's been doing one thing for a
decade how does she
stop most people you know my dad told me
once he said you know I asked them do
people change and my dad said no they
get worse over time so whatever traits
you see now make sure you like them
because in 10 years or 20 30 4 years
going be 10 times worse and how do you
search the on wait s you TR
out the
Vol um so how do you stop her like the
things you don't
like you just up it world this to like
well so if you hate one thing it's like
you're done if you hate what I don't she
just me 10 times worse then what do you
ha about M nothing just as there's got
to be something what do you not like
about me I don't there there's nothing I
like oh that oh okay did you hear what I
said what there's nothing like about way
I just I just an example of a dangerous
tra of course I like everything I'll
give you an example of a dangerous trait
for men that I think gets worse over
time I would say spite so I would say be
careful with women that are spiteful
because those are typically the women
that BR you in divorce court and spite
um those are typically the women that
keep score so I do so much for you I do
this this this and this you never win
with a chick that's she's not like that
all I'm not I'm not saying she's an no
say that's the thing yeah yeah so um if
I had to pick like one I would actually
pick that trait as worse than like um
forom I would actually say to avoid
spitefulness more than AV them even
though like avoid both obviously for
life so that's a never ending game yeah
as you can't win because you she said
like a [__] it's like CLA isn't well
and and women typically tend to focus on
herself helps so it's like is she like
so we often don't notice the things that
I mean I'm sure that's happened to you
guys where you do a lot for a chick
Ching to notice at some
point then what would I do that get em
most what I I don't know but I'm saying
this is a common complaint that I hear
from men is that they will do a lot for
a girl and they don't appreciate
it yeah most girls like that exactly
yeah all all CU all brother is dumb like
you see like Rand R like um like you
don't understand I I have a conversation
you tell you something and like s told
you not to do something you have in the
back of your mind yo I can't do that I'm
not going to do that and like most
business just forget and not forget they
like they want to do it for attention
they want they want their
attention it's
likeo like flair for instance she wanted
attention so she left her car in the
middle of [__] drive withing drive
her three days because she wanted me to
call her to answer her text for once you
know have and
like lowy do [__] do that and she
like plays down yeah I mean all of the
movements really are targeted towards
women you know with who own who on BLM
as EV of lesbian jokes you know same
thing with uh F yeah exactly men don't
care enough to they want to make money
well women want women want to be loud
well they're just well men just turn is
emotional and and and they will what'll
happen is they'll pray upon women's like
um a instincts So like um basically like
the propaganda
thing that I see is here is this oral
thing that happened and here I'm selling
you the solution or I'm going to pass a
policy to take away your freedom so you
know um should woman be able to vote oh
God
no yes and and the reason being is I
think if we want to vote we need to be
we need to have the same
responsibilities as well I have no
problem with women voting that you know
pay ta that are not tax payers that but
the reality is that majority of women
are in debt right they're in debt they
don't do hard jobs they don't infl like
men do everything hard in society I
think they should have more say um and
until women want to do that I don't
really believe we should have the same
say as men and it's also the question is
what policies do you like I'm foring fix
but I the question is like what policies
do you want to pass like do you want
policies that are for individuals or for
families it used to be that you had one
vote for the family but now we're
encouraging a society
individuals um so I I you know I think a
lot of men should have had would love to
take the s men out of this too you know
let's take them out what you mean like
with the G no no like they should have
voted either you know I don't think the
crackhead down the street claim they
should vote but to act like women and
men are the same when it comes to voting
uh women are the biggest swing voting
block you know and I wanted to figure
out why men um why there's so many
policies that discriminate against men
like in Family Court um even in in uh
Criminal Court sentences me to all that
stuff and the reason is because all of
the politicians have to cater to women
and the anti-suffragists which a group
of like wives and mothers from a 100
years ago they knew this and they warned
they said that the women that wanted to
vote were spinsters with no families and
they said if if women get to vote this
will be the end of the family unit then
we will see an increase in government
spending you're going to see the
families disappear well they were right
what happened a hundred years later um I
think third 40% of kids are born out of
wedlock now um and before the age of
nine I want to say the majority of the
parents are divorce so that's what
that's what's happening and the question
is do we think that's a good thing or a
bad thing I would argue a Bad Thing
Progressive see it is a good day should
men be able to just hit
women uh I I mean women I think they
should hit women that hit first oh yeah
but I don't think people should be
hitting any body